today once again fundamentally nothing
new has happened
all human affairs are rehearsals with
the same themes played out against a
mildly changing background but merely
articulating the essential futility of
existence and the damn nature of
humankind chat like a fly in the bottle
of life we bring you a tree which today
moved lightly in the breeze there is so
much to be grateful for we should note
that in some cases wisdom did prevail
certain potential murderers did not
today pick up a knife certain sorts of
rage were defused for now some would-be
adulterers had second thoughts certain
would-be suicide bombers saw into the
eyes of a child and could not do it we
are no better than the beasts in the
earthworm's the lugs and the anthropods
this individual here puts us to shame in
any case the most important things have
happened today have not occurred out
there in the plains of Anatolia or the
straits of Singapore or the corridors of
the Pentagon but in your own soul that
fast unexplored region itself
no more studied than the dark side of a
far-off planet in some distant galaxy
if you like our films take a look at our
shop the School of Life comm forward
slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you